rumors of a mass effect trilogy remaster
have sparked up again
you can finally save space on your pc if
you've got modern warfare installed
and a ps4 update preps for ps5 remote
play
i'm lucy let's get going
something called the mass effect
legendary edition has been rated in
korea
the listing doesn't have any details
about the game but legendary edition is
the supposed name for the remastered
trilogy that includes mass effect 1
2 and 3. there have been a lot of hopes
for and
rumors of the mass effect trilogy to be
remastered an
earlier report from gamesbeat stated
that the remaster has slipped
into a 2021 release date november 7th
aka n7 day is little less than a month
away
so if ea is going to announce this
trilogy soon
that would be an ideal time to do it as
always
take rumors with a pinch of salt but i'm
a huge mass effect fan
i really hope this one happens call of
duty
modern warfares file sizes are out of
control the game is currently around
200 gigabytes the latest update though
helps at least pc
players save space by letting them
uninstall unwanted game modes
for example a lot of players don't
revisit single player once they've
completed the campaign
so now they can remove it from their
hard drive now this feature has actually
been available on playstation 4 for some
time now but only for those who own the
digital version of the game
if you want to see the full modern
warfare patch notes head on over to
gamespot
and speaking of the playstation 4
there's a new firmware update
that helps look ahead to the playstation
5. update 8.0 adds the option to connect
the ps5 to the remote play app on mobile
phones and pc
now with this you can hop into ps5
remote play on day one when the console
launches
on november 12th party chat and messages
are also more closely linked now
and sony confirmed cross-gen messaging
is happening so you can send messages
from ps4 to ps5 and vice versa
the firmware also adds new profile
avatar options and the option to use
third-party authenticator apps for
two-factor authentication
but apparently the update has also
caused issues accessing friends lists
but playstation are working on a fix on
tomorrow's episode of generation next we
go through all the biggest ps5 and
series x news stories from this week
as well as go through final hands-on
impressions of the series
x it's also prime day so if you head
over to gamespot.com you can find a
roundup of all the best gaming deals
so take a look we'll see you next time
[Music]
you